[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 on va
s'intéresser ce soir à la sécurité dans
le pacifique sud et à cet affrontement
entre les états unis et la chine au
surlendemain du tour d'asie de joe biden
les états unis focaliser sur l'ukraine
n'oublient pas leurs adversaires chinois
dans cette zone stratégique
anthony blinken ne veut pas de conflit
ou de nouvelle guerre froide avec la
chine at il lancé et pourtant joe biden
a passé plusieurs jours entre séoul et
tokyo et a ravivé le quad cette alliance
avec l'inde et le japon mais aussi avec
l'australie le quad qui vise à contenir
l'expansionnisme de la chine by dunn a
réitéré l'engagement américain de à
défendre taiwan en cas d'agression
chinoise le ministre des affaires
étrangères chinois est d'ailleurs en ce
moment même aux îles salomon où est
évoqué une coopération en matière de
sécurité et économique les tensions sont
donc bel et bien accrue en asie
pacifique les états unis avance-t-il
leurs pions dans la région le quad est
signée justement avec le japon l'inde et
l'australie est il une sorte d' autant
pour la région asie pacifique contre la
chine que fait la chine aux îles salomon
et quid de l'australie qui a un nouveau
chef du gouvernement vous le savez le
travailliste anthony albanais c'est
reviendra-t-il sur le coup de trafalgar
imposer à la france avec la rupture du
contrat sur les sous marins on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
à mes côtés et guybourg de la motte
bonsoir mon son maître de conférences à
l'inalco aux tristes de la démocratie au
japon singulière et universel sauté aux
éditions pardon de la haine s et puis
vous avez également publié géopolitique
et géoéconomique du monde contemporain
puissance et conflits et ça c'est aux
éditions la découverte ils sont avec
vous bienvenue dans le débat en face de
vous jean joseph boillot bonsoir bonsoir
chercheur associé à l'iris hauteur de
l'inde au chevet de nos politiques et
c'est aux éditions du félin à vous êtes
spécialiste des grands pays émergents
merci d'être avec nous nous avons avec
nous par skype de londres pierre-antoine
donnait bonsoir ancien correspondant de
l'afp et à pékin hauteur de chine le
grand prédateur aux éditions de l'aube
et puis également 2
le leadership mondial en question
bienvenue à vous bonsoir sonia dridi
notre correspondante est avec nous en
direct de washington merci sonia d'être
avec nous pour ce débat
avant de démarrer cette discussion va
revenir tout de suite d'abord sur ces
tensions dans cette zone en asie
pacifique avec justement ce récit on
regarde tout de suite
on m'informe que nous n'avons pas notre
sujet alors on va écouter tout de suite
anthony blinken le secrétaire d'état
américain qui s'est exprimé il ya
quelques instants justement sur ces
tensions
la vision de pétillant et nous
éloignerait des valeurs universelles sur
soutenu une grande partie des progrès du
monde au cours des 75 dernières années
la chine fait également partie
intégrante de l'économie mondiale et de
notre capacité à résoudre des problèmes
allant du climat au co vide
ce bris en d'autres termes les états
unis et la chine doivent traiter
ensemble à l'avenir c'est pourquoi il
s'agit de l'une des relations les plus
complexes et les plus importantes dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui
on va faire le point en images avec
mounia kacem
le drapeau chinois c'est sur les îles
salomon pékin a dépêché sur cet archipel
du pacifique
son chef de la diplomatie après la
signature d'un accord de sécurité entre
les deux nouveaux partenaires
la chine a toujours fermement soutenu
les îles salomon dans le maintien de
leur souveraineté nationale de leur
sécurité et de leur intégrité
territoriale cela servira de modèle de
confiance politique mutuelle entre la
chine et les pays insulaires du
pacifique sud car la chine n'entend pas
s'arrêter aux îles salomon pékin va
proposer à 10 est insulaire du pacifique
sud un accord régional de libre échange
et de sécurité le chef de la diplomatie
chinoise soumettra cette proposition
notamment aux îles fidji où se trouve
justement son homologue australienne
face à l'offensive diplomatique chinoise
l'australie contre attaque et propose
son accord canberra a annoncé une
intensification de son engagement dans
le pacifique avec environ 500 millions
de dollars australiens dead pour la
formation à la défense ou encore la
sécurité maritime
l'australie sera un partenaire qui ne
viendra pas avec des conditions ni
n'imposera des charges financières
insoutenable nous sommes un partenaire
qu'il ne rendra pas les priorités où les
institutions du pacifique
les nations insulaires du pacifique
feront leur choix quant aux accords
qu'elle souhaite conclure au partenariat
dans lesquelles elles s'engagent
les etats-unis et leurs alliés du quad
dans la région l'australie l'inde et le
japon voit d'un mauvais oeil l'influencé
grandissante de la chine et les
manoeuvres militaires de pékin en asie
pacifique en début de semaine les quatre
pays ont d'ailleurs mis en garde la
chine contre l'emploi de la force dans
la région le président américain joe
biden avait affirmé lundi que les
etats-unis seraient prêts à défendre
militairement taiwan en cas d'invasion
par la chine avant de tempérer ses
propos le lendemain
sonia dridi vous êtes avec nous en
direct de washington anthony blinken
donc a fait une cette allocution cet
après midi il a fait la différence entre
le régime chinois et le peuple chinois
les etats-unis avance-t-il leurs pions
en indo pacifique face à la chine
alors avec ce discours à les états unis
voulaient veulent clairement établir
leur position face à la chine alors que
on le sait il ya un regain de tensions
entre washington et pékin et puis entre
ce discours d' anthony blinken et la
récente visite de joe biden en asie et
bien l'administration
buydens veut montrer que l'asie reste
une priorité alors que évidemment elle a
été très mobilisées ces derniers mois
sur l'ukraine blinken qui a notamment
déclaré que la chine était le seul pays
qui avaient l'intention et les moyens
diplomatiques économiques militaires de
redéfinir l'ordre international de
promouvoir une vision différente et
d'ailleurs lors de sa tournée en asie
joe biden avait évoqué une compétition
mondiale entre les démocraties et les
autocraties donc vraiment les états unis
perçoivent la chine comme une menace en
plus une menace commercial également une
menace géopolitique et anthony blinken
dans ce discours a aussi dénoncé la
chine qui respectent pas les règles
établies donc notamment dans ces
conflits enchaîne en chine 2 en mer de
chine méridionale
mais c'est vrai que c'était intéressant
de noter le ton de blink qui était très
différent par exemple du thon de
l'ancien président donald trump de
l'ancienne administration il est apparu
moins dans la confrontation il a
notamment insisté sur le fait que les
états unis ne voulaient pas de nouvelle
guerre froide qu'elle ne voulait pas de
conflit mais blinken a aussi dit que il
ne fallait pas s'attendre à ce que la
chine change de trajectoire et donc pour
faire face à la chine est bien il a
plaidé plus pour plus d'innovation aux
états unis plus de compétition et puis
une renforcement des alliances notamment
avec les pays de la région indo
pacifique à pierre-antoine donnait
justement pour rebondir sur ce que vient
dire sonia ces stratégies d'alliance des
états unis est ce que ça ressemble
finalement à la stratégie d'endiguement
des années 50 contre l'union soviétique
est ce que effectivement aujourd'hui
byden et les états unis veulent digue et
la chine dans en asie pacifique
il est dit que les états unis ne veulent
pas d'une guerre froide en fait les
états unis et la chine sont déjà entrés
dans une ère de guerre froide c'est très
clair et on voit bien que depuis son
arrivée à la maison blanche joe biden sa
priorité c'est la chine la montée en
puissance de la chine dans la région
asie pacifique sur les plans économique
ça c'est très clair la chine est
maintenant la deuxième puissance
économique du monde mais également
économique et surtout militaire et avec
en filigrane l'île de taïwan contre
laquelle les menaces chinoises se
précise de ces derniers mois avec des
bombardiers des chasseurs qui rentre de
façon assez régulière dont la zone
l'identification aux militaires de
taiwan et le but est double d'un côté
c'est intimité la population de taiwan
vous faire en sorte que taiwan accepte
sans compas de se soumettre à la chine
de populaires et d'autre part de montrer
aux états unis que la chine est très
ferme dans son intention de parvenir à
une réunification ce qu'elle considère
comme une réification de taiwan à ce
qu'on appelle la mère patrie change
devraient donc ça veut dire que la chine
tissent des alliances c'est ce que dit
c'est ce qu'on voit ce qu'a montré le
sujet y compris aujourd'hui puisque le
ministre chinois et aux îles salomon
qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire d'ailleurs
dans les îles salomon dit qu'elle veut
mettre une base militaire elle a une
approche très sécuritaire de la zone
contre les états unis contre l'occident
moi je pense pas j'ai pas cette vision
là je pense que c'est une question de
rééquilibrage dans la zone on viendra
sur le rôle très important de l'inde en
particulier dans la nature du
rééquilibrage si vous prenez la carte de
l'océan pacifique
non la halle haas et de l'inde au
pacifique a réalisé le salon la wii mes
amis
de ce qui s'est passé c'est après guerre
lorsque la chine passe au régime
communiste vous avez un rapport de force
qui est de 99 pour les etats-unis de 1 %
pour la chine et la puissance économique
chinoise s'était rappelée pardonner et
maintenant qu'ils valente en fait à
celle des états unis et donc il ya une
approche ce qui était annoncé par thank
you ping qui est simplement de faire
reculer ce mur américain qui est à
quelques dizaines centaines de
kilomètres donc et bien entendu
mais la question est de savoir est-ce
que s'il faut en avoir une vision
militaire agressive ou est ce qu'il faut
en avoir une vision stratégique et celle
du rééquilibrage dans la région entre un
pôle d'alliance et ça c'est très
important le quad de ce point de vue là
parce qu'il avait été mis en hibernation
pendant pas mal d'années et servait
seulement vers 2018 à peu près et donc
c'est un nouveau quad qui est en train
d'émerger moi je laisse jamais aller
peut comparer à l'otan par exemple et
non pas du tout c'est une alliance
militaire et économique non pas du tout
justement ça qui est intéressant c'est
que j'ai des états unis une partie de go
1 qui se déroulent dans la région qui
est à et élargit maintenant à l'inde au
pacifique parce qu'effectivement l'asie
pacifique en elle-même ne réglait pas le
problème du détroit de malacca et de
l'action moyen-orient et donc chacun
cherche trouve son équilibre la chine
avance ses pions les états unis
répondent je pense que la diplomatie se
définit comme cela et donc je ne pense
pas qu'ils aient une volonté de
containement de la chine d'ailleurs les
indiens ont voté traînait là dessus on
sait pas mais par contre ya une volonté
d'équilibré on voit bien que dollar des
états unis ou de la part de la chine non
de la part du japon etats unis australie
etc qui se rendent bien compte que la
puissance chinoise de l'expansionnisme
chinois doit être
contrebalancé rééquilibrer donc c'est
une partie intéressante et je pense pas
en tout cas qu'on soit aujourd'hui dans
une situation de type autant ou
précaires je n'ai pas le sentiment du
bord de la mode vous êtes d'accord vous
qui connaissez très bien le japon le
premier ministre japonais on a vu qu'il
s'est plutôt rapproché de joe biden
d'ailleurs il tenait à tokyo joe biden
c'est pas pour rien est ce que le japon
fait aujourd'hui partie de ce bloc
occidental face à la chine oui je crois
je crois qu'il est
illzach de parler de tentative de
rééquilibrage face en effet un
expansionnisme chinois qu'on observe
avec les îles salomon en fait la
difficulté et enfin le point qui nous
inquiète collectivement disons les
occidentaux les australiens qui étaient
très présents dans la région et qu'ils
sont toujours d'ailleurs et bien c'est
que la chine par l'accord qui a été
signé donc avec les îles salomon peut
éventuellement envoyer des soldats pour
défendre les investissements que c'était
un fait sur place ils devraient
peut-être y mettre une base militaire en
tout cas c'est ce que craignent les
occidentaux disons qu'à partir du moment
où elle commence à déployer déployés en
effet avoir le droit par un accord de
déployer en effet des militaires s'est
passé c'est en effet en approche en
effet d'une base d'une base
le japon le japon effectivement comme
les états unis a vraiment activement
donc une stratégie de rééquilibrage face
à en fait une situation que le japon
subit lui en permanence d'incursions
aériennes maritimes et puis et puis le
japon est tout proche aussi la mer de
chine méridionale où de fait la chine a
conquis des positions qu'on peut plus
reprendre maintenant c'est à dire qu'on
s'efforce d'affirmer la liberté de
circulation dans cette zone mais quelle
position eh bien eh bien en fait la
chine a militarisé des récifs qui
n'étaient pas des îles au regard du
droit international est là s'est
accaparé la zone qui était contestée par
les philippines l'indonésie la malaisie
notamment brunet également le vietnam
également et puis elle en a fait des
bases militaires et hattab le mans donc
on il s'agirait pas qu il se passe la
même chose dans l'inde au pacifique d'où
ce rééquilibrage dont parle jean joseph
boillot seriez d'accord avec ce terme
oui le terme de rééquilibrage me paraît
juste dans la mesure où on voit disons
une montée en puissance considérable de
la chine qui se produit par le biais
d'investissements économiques à visée
stratégique et donc de plus en plus les
les volets économiques et sécuritaires
sont liés ils apparaissent de plus de
plus en plus clairement comme comme lié
dans l'est dans les propositions
nouvelles de la chine est donc de fait
on est
on cherche à maintenir notre avantage si
on veut du point de vue chinois mais
enfin de notre point de vue à défendre
le droit international à défendre la
liberté de circulation en mer à défendre
la liberté des états qui reçoivent des
investissements de continuer ensuite à
elle respecte ses principes la chine
dans la chine justement non c'est notre
problème en effet donc c'est inégal
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on
s'organise
d'où le quad alors parmi les absents du
quad en tout cas où de l'accord régional
économique taiwan taiwan puisque
washington donc a affirmé qu'il voulait
un accord bilatéral et stratégique avec
taïwan donc ne fait pas partie taiwan de
ce quad baden a réitéré d'ailleurs
l'engagement américain à défendre taiwan
en cas d'agression chinoise pékin a
affirmé que les remarques de joe biden
donc fait cette semaine à ce sujet et
bien aurait des conséquences
irrémédiables on écoute joe biden
non
notre politique n'a pas changé du tout
je les dis quand j'ai fait ma
déclaration hier
sonia ce que joe biden va plus loin dans
son engagement militaire auprès de
taïwan face à la chine que c'est mon
prédécesseur
alors
joe biden attendant selon le ca faire
beaucoup de gaffes à dire tout haut ce
que son administration souhaiterait
qu'ils ne disent pas et on l'a vue là il
a rétropédalé c'est vrai que il a lors
de sa tournée en asie dit que les états
unis et bien défendre et militairement
taiwan si pékin envahissent et donc
l'île autonome et puis dès le lendemain
devant les journalistes vous avez passé
l'extrait il a dit que les états unis et
bien ne remet tait pas en cause
l'ambiguïté stratégique et ce qui est la
politique des etats-unis face avec
taïwan il y a aussi eu dans le discours
dans tony blinken tout à l'heure le
secrétaire d'état américain dont qui a
déclaré que washington ne soutenait pas
l'indépendance de taiwan est aussi le
pentagone s'est empressé après la
première remarque joe biden de dire que
la doctrine des états unis à face à
taiwan ne changeait pas mais ce qu'on
observe c'est que du côté du congrès il
y a plusieurs démocrates qui disent
qu'ils espèrent que ce n'était pas une
gaffe de la part de baden que en tout
cas beaucoup savent que hayden pense
vraiment cela et on voit quand même
certains élus
notamment des démocrates au congrès bien
qu'ils appellent à à mettre fin
finalement à cette stratégie d'
ambiguïté à cette ambiguïté stratégique
avec taïwan on sent qu après l'agression
de l'ukraine par la russie et bien il y
a de plus en plus d'élus qui lève la
voix qui disent que la chine est un
bulli c'est un bolide de ce monde au
kaki qui finalement agressent
plusieurs plusieurs autres pays dans le
monde et donc qui le pousse finalement à
joe biden a peut-être à abandonner cette
ambiguïté stratégique et qui qui était
finalement plutôt satisfait que haydn et
c'est pas ces paroles assez forte face à
la chine mme on a vu donc qu'il a
rétropédalé par la suite en tout cas
c'est vrai que là tous les yeux à
washington sont rivés vers la chine on
le sait on parlait même au début de
l'administration bailon d'une obsession
chinois c'est vrai que c'est vraiment la
priorité de cette administration qui a
été accaparé ces derniers mois par le
dossier ukrainien mais qu'il a on le
voit et bien finalement veut montrer à
la chine qu'elle est prête à agir si
éventuellement et bien il y aurait une
agression de taïwan l'action chinoise ne
s'est pas fait attendre
oui tout à fait c'est pour ça que aussi
que joe biden a rétropédalé parce qu'on
voit aussi ils jouent enfin
l'administration maiden joue un peu le
chaud et le froid et on l'a bien vu dans
le discours de blinken qui a dit que la
diplomatie était vitale ils ne veulent
pas non plus être être trop confondent
dans la confrontation avec la chine
comme l'était davantage par exemple
l'ancien président donald trump donc
c'est vrai que c'était intéressant de
voir ce rétropédalage mais finalement le
ceo joe biden c'est ce qu'il pense
vraiment et ils on sait aussi qu'ils
connais très bien que si jean ping parce
que lorsqu il était le vice-président de
barack obama il a beaucoup côtoyé et
et vraiment je pense que après cette
agression notamment de l'ukraine par la
russie et bien les voix s'élèvent au
congrès pour être plus dur face à la
ville dire les choses et dire clairement
que si la chine s'en prend à taïwan
voilà il y aura une réaction militaire
alors je voulais qu'on écoute justement
la réaction chinoise elle n'est pas
venue mais vous avez répondu à la
question sonia pierre antoine donnait
byden est-ce qu'il tire finalement et
leçons de la guerre en ukraine est ce qu
un parallèle à faire
finalement est-ce que en intervenant de
manière aussi dû en étant dur avec
poutine est ce que c'est une manière de
lancer un signal à pékin un tout un fait
d'abord je te dire que ce qu'a dit biden
lundi ce n'est pas une gaffe c'est
palace et palabres et enfin qui dit ça
c'est la deuxième fois il ya 10 de façon
très claire alors certes il a
rétropédalé parce qu'il se rend compte
qu effectivement la portée de ce qu'il a
dit est immense mais c'est vraiment ce
qu'il pense donc il dit les choses
nettement il attache beaucoup
d'importance au moindre mot qu'il
prononce à propos de la chine maintenant
le contexte effectivement observé
l'agression russe en ukraine est en
train de provoquer un bouleversement
total de la carte géopolitique du monde
la grande inquiétude a été et est
toujours est ce que la chine populaire
en particulier son président xi jinping
va-t-il à en profiter pour lancer
l'assaut contre taïwan personnellement
je pense que non ou une raison très
simple enfin deux réseaux à vrai dire la
première c'est que l'équilibré des
traces des forces face à l'armée
populaire de libération est énorme parce
que
tout à l'heure
il a été dit par guy bord de la mode que
effectivement la position du japon a
changé elle a changé de façon radicale
l'ancien premier ministre japonais
shinzo abe l'année dernière a dit de
façon très nette devant les caméras une
agression chinoise contre taïwan ce
serait une agression contre le japon ces
propos sont extrêmement important parce
que là c'est très clair en cas
d'agression chinoise contre taïwan non
seulement les états unis interviendrait
sur le plan militaire mais le japon
serait aux côtés des états unis alors
certes on ne verrait pas les troupes
japonaises débarqué à taïwan ça c'est
inimaginable mais il y aurait
certainement un appui logistique du
japon pour assister les forces
militaires américaines à taïwan d'autre
part il ya encore d'autres choses il ya
aussi la corée du sud la corée du sud
sur le plan militaire réussi ces
dernières années une percée
extraordinaire absolument extraordinaire
et aujourd'hui on voit bien que malgré
les tensions énormes qui ont qui avait
entre la corée du sud et le japon ont
des raisons historiques que tout le
monde connaît et bien aujourd'hui les
sondages en corée du sud sont très
claires l'ennemi aujourd'hui n'est plus
le japon mais la chine donc
cette redistribution des cartes
géopolitiques
elle aura des conséquences très très
forte sur les années qui viennent et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
anthony blinken eux le rappeler le la
priorité de la diplomatie américaine
c'est la chine et moi je pense que ça va
au delà d'une simple d'un simple
rééquilibrage des forces moi je persiste
à dire que ilya belyaev bel et bien
aujourd'hui une guerre froide parce que
qui s'installe dans cette zone oui parce
que la chance elle est aussi militaire
le budget militaire chinois est certes
très loin derrière le budget militaire
américain mais on voit bien que la chine
tisse sa toile la chine texas toile je
vais faire réagir jean jacques boileau
est ce que vous venez de jean-jacques
pardon jean joseph boillot fumât
pardonnez moi j'ai
bjb ok donc est ce que vous pouvez
réagir justement là effectivement il dit
quelque chose d'un peu différent
quarantaine d'années s'est plus
seulement du rééquilibrage mines logique
de blu ray voilà l'opinion c'est
l'opinion de données on la connaît
depuis longtemps la chine étape est
terrible et c'est non mais appelle
l'attention du kenya effectivement à
tournon gens au nom duquel on assiste ou
pas non au contraire moi je vous dis
j'ai pas de logique de bloc on l'aurait
vu lors de ce sommet moi ce qui me
frappe à ce sommet c'est qu'on ne peut
plus la règle alors qu'elles soient bien
parlez vous de tokyo ce m
joba il faut lire le communiqué final
tant les ce qui est important diplomatie
c'est dire un communiqué final et pas
prendre des petites phrases dans ce
communiqué final ni là aussi n'est
mentionnée et la guerre en ukraine
pourquoi parce que lundi n'ont donc
c'est très important ni la posture
agressive de la chine n'hésite et
pourquoi pas parce que les indiens ont
des problèmes de frontières mais ils
sont en train d'en discuter et ils ne
veulent surtout pas l'âne qui fait
partie du quad en faut le rappeler non
mais attendez le vous enlevez la nga
plus de quad elle le problème il est
tout simple donc la grande puissance
démographique économique qui attire et
le quad vers l'inde au pacifique puisque
à l'époque c'était uniquement le
pacifique a aussi sa ligne directrice
est ce qui me paraît la grande décision
de ce quad de ce sommet c'est 50
milliards de dollars sur la table pour
le développement économique de la région
et ça si vous mais ça ça fait partie de
la façade avant que des mix a fait
partie justement des armes on pourrait
dire guybourg de la motte qu utilisent
aussi les états unis dans le cadre de
cette alliance est militaire et
économique alors je sais c'est un
rapprochement sont des partenariats
effectivement avec des partenaires qui
ont des logiques différentes des
manières de voir la chine différentes
mais enfin une volonté commune et en
moins alors avec des degrés divers des
et
une fermeté qui varient même parfois en
fonction d administration l a vu avec
l'administration américaine mais comme
et donc mais quand même la volonté de
travailler ensemble pour en fait et
c'est la logique du japon en premier
lieu c'est de ne pas donner le sentiment
à la chine qu'elle est exclu qu'on y est
hostile qu'on met autant de données
avait l'air de dire quelle il est
beaucoup plus dur aujourd'hui le japon à
l'égard de la chine il est à l'huile est
née entre de bons gars faudrait qu'on
ait quand même vigilants donc 1 avec
avec un japon qui donc en effet comme
comme les états unis mais beaucoup
d'argent dans danser dans ces pays là le
japon a changé mais c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que depuis en fait au moins 80 18
même même avant le japon très clairement
avait commencé a indiqué que taiwan et
est un sujet de préoccupation pour sa
sécurité et en 98 et une loi avait été
adoptée pour lui permettre déjà de
donner un soutien de ce qu'on pense dans
cette région est ce que les japonais
pense qu'effectivement si la chine
envahissait taiwan les états unis
interviendrait militairement est ce que
c'est ce qu'on pense là bah oui ça bien
sûr absolument c'est donc l'engagement
dont parle joe biden on y croit oui un
bon jeu les oui c'est un saint en effet
oui et je pense que je pense que la
chine la chine pense également que ce
serait ce que serait ce qu'il se
passerait donc ce rapport de force en
fait tu freines je dirais les velléités
chinoises éventuellement non parce que
je crois que la chine la chine si elle
n'en vaille pas taïwan aussi c'est parce
que la bonne raison de ne pas le faire
c'est que les taiwanais leçons n'ont pas
n'ont pas n'ont pas non plus envie
d'être rattachée à la à la chine de
cette manière dont il ya il ya de fait
la volonté plutôt de séduire le les
taïwanais l'exemple qu'on a eue avec ans
qu'on n'est pas de nature à tellement
séduire les taiwanais parce qu'ils sont
une démocratie qui fonctionne
complètement donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
une incompatibilité dans les systèmes et
pour la chine c'est le prochain il y
avait en kong sur lequel on met la main
et ensuite taiwan s'est tout de même ça
donc on est ce que jamais un
rapprochement sera possible je n'en sais
rien mais jean joseph boillot subite
active sur cet angle qui déjà parle de
guerre froide etc etc je pense que vous
avez deux géants si vous voulez le
l'épicentre mondial il n'est pas en
ukraine il est en europe il a
effectivement en asie l'ensemble des
facteurs contribuent à dire que c'est là
que les choses se passent et donc la
question c'est qu'est ce que vous faites
lorsque vous êtes confrontés à une
puissance montante et à une puissance
que pas déclinantes des états unis mais
qui tout seul en tout cas a besoin
d'alliés et moi je trouve extrêmement
intéressant ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est à dire que le rôle de la
diplomatie et de la géopolitique est de
précisément contenir de ce point de vue
là ya pas de containement de la chine
mais de contenir ce qui pourrait être
très rapidement un basculement
effectivement à la faveur en faveur de
la chine et c'est pour ça que je répète
l'épicente c'est là-bas mais maintenant
le pivot du pivot c'est l'inde et donc
si on ne tient pas on prend pas en
compte ce qui va être les priorités ce
qui est des priorités à la fois
militaires ce qui est très important le
quad on l'oubli c'est un ensemble
d'exercices navale c'est probablement la
seule chose qu'a vraiment marcher sur le
plan militaire et ça marche très bien
malabar le japon l'australie sont
associés maintenant ça ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que la chine sait qu'elle
peut plus faire ce qu'elle veut dans
cette région lors que celles-ci les ont
totalement pardonnez moi mais que
fait-elle aux îles salomon elle voudrait
d'accord sécuritaire elle voudrait
peut-être pouvoir même intervenir dans
la politique intérieure c'est du vietnam
c'est évident fin jeudi il faut bien
comprendre que quand vous avez une
superpuissance et puis une puissance qui
monte il veut aussi être une super
puissance elle va essayer de poser des
pions partout c'est évident et donc
l'accord avec les îles salomon cette
année c'est plus de 20 ans de
coopération économique et technique
aussi de la chine ne faut pas l'oublier
c'est pas d'hier qui a une percée
mériadeck rédacteur est évidemment dans
la région et à la france et puis à
l'australie on va on va y revenir
justement alors l'australie joue un rôle
très important parce qu'on on n'y prend
pas garde mais c'est quand même le flanc
sud 1 du quad
et les relations avec l'inde sont
excellentes il ya un accord de libre
échange qui a été passée et signer enfin
ça c'est à peu près certain et donc vous
avez vous avez quatre puissances à
l'intérieur du quad et puis vous avez un
jeu de billard entre chacune et
vis-à-vis de la région donc c'est
complexe voilà je pense pas qu'on puisse
trancher aujourd'hui en disant ça y est
la nouvelle guerre froide et l'arbre
mais y en a qui pensent à un
véritablement non plus trop que le toute
façon les parallèles sont toujours un
peu facile et un peu excessif enfin
lacie fin c'est la situation de la
guerre froide était était un épisode
particulier je crois que c'est par
simplicité journalistique on aime parler
guerre froide à nouveau je pense que les
foyers de 60 actions de blocs peut-être
il ya en tout cas d'aidé logique
d'équilibré et de fait c'est on observe
attentivement ce que fait la chine parce
qu'elle investit massivement dans des
minerais stratégiques parce que elle
absorbe énormément de souvenirs aux
innovations combat on essaye de
contrôler précisément facilement par des
investissements pas en étant attractive
pour ces pays qui d'ailleurs fait monter
les enchères et ils ont bien raison
l'australie justement on va en parler le
chef de l'opposition travailliste
anthony albanese et donc lui a emporté
les élections c'était dimanche dernier
il avait beaucoup critiqué scott
morrison son prédécesseur il avait
critiqué de n'avoir pas réussi je cite à
empêcher la signature d'un accord des
chinois dans justement une région où
l'australie a traditionnellement une
grande influence en l'occurrence il est
alité très critique à l'égard de la
non-action de son prédécesseur à l'égard
de la chine dans les îles salomon on va
écouter anthony albanese et
n'étaient pas
engagés véritablement dans le pacifique
c'est pourquoi penny wong ministre des
affaires étrangères qui est revenu avec
moi de tokyo hier soir est déjà en route
pour les fidji et pour informer le
gouvernement que nous voulons
intensifier notre engagement à
rejeter pas mais qui m'aurait mode vous
qui est la spécialiste un peu de
l'australie il va être plus offensifs
dans la région comme ils disent tu as
pop pour utiliser le terme anglais
jeu oui alors je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit sur ce plan là qu'il rentre le plus
avec scott mécénat dirai pas ce que
c'est vrai que la logique de
rapprochement avec donc qui nous a
défavorisé en temps les français des
durs du royaume uni et puis et puis des
états unis a été donc démarré par scott
morrison et on est tout à fait dans
cette logique de rééquilibrage est donc
là il s'agit de prolonger cette logique
de fait mais d'investir massivement dans
auprès des voisins ce qui était un ce
qui est important en effet donc alliance
économique
on n'investit plus mais ils le prennent
comme une menace cette présence chinoise
dans les îles salomon les australiens
oui tout à fait parce que c'est à deux
pas de chez eux en effet et puis et puis
parce que même même en australie mais il
ya des investissements chinois
extrêmement important donc donc en effet
bruce à un recul c'est ce qui veut dire
en fait quand il critique est justement
son prédécesseur qui avait un recul
justement de l'affluence australienne
dans cette région réveiller un recul
relatif bien sûr
est-ce que l' australie var ont changé
ses relations avec les états unis sonia
être peut-être plus proche encore en
tout cas on voit ces derniers temps
voilà qui est un renforcement des
relations entre l'australie et les états
vivent ce que l'australie tout comme les
états unis on le sait craignent que
pékin notamment installer une base
militaire dans les îles salomon on a
aussi vu évidemment que la coopération
et de renforcer avec le quad que joe
biden a tenu
a donc à voir cette cette réunion
dernier dernièrement on en a beaucoup
parlé ici à washington
donc je pense qu'on peut parler d'une
coopération renforcée ils ont les mêmes
intérêts dans la région est et voilà
encore une fois c'est une priorité des
états unis c'est d'autant plus encore
plus une priorité aussi la chine
aujourd'hui pour les états unis parce
que les washington a été très embêté de
voir que la chine pourrait pouvait aider
la russie à contourner les sanctions
économiques est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui encore dans son discours
anthony blinken a dit que l'amitié entre
la russie et la chine devraient alerter
tout le monde on va écouter d'ailleurs
maintenant jean yves le drian l'ancien
chef de la diplomatie française qui
restait dix ans à ce poste ont jusqu'à
tout récemment c'était
vous allez voir ce qu'il dit justement
de scott morrison
va pas m'empêcher de dire que la défaite
du 1er mai horribilis morrison ne
convient très bien
parce que les actes posés à l'égard de
la france
au moment où ils ont été posées
étaient d'une brutalité d'un cynisme et
je rends même tenté de dire d'une forme
d'incompétence notoire
pierre-antoine donné vous est peut-être
réagira évidemment il fait allusion à ce
contrat ce contrat qui était contrat du
siècle sur les sous-marins qui est donc
été littéralement annulés un peu du jour
au lendemain par les australiens
s'alliant d'ailleurs aux états unis est
là à la grande bretagne est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça va changer les choses
ce changement c'est arrivées d'anthony
albanaise et à écouter d'abord le
nouveau prêt une liste australien son
objectif il essaie d'abord le changement
climatique ça c'est sa priorité mais
pour revenir cet accord tripartite
caucus à écouter je comprends très bien
qui évidemment il ya eu un certain
désarroi du côté français qui explique
d'ailleurs les propos que le cul bien de
tenir mon service des affaires
étrangères d'ailleurs un peu avant dhabi
sont pas très élégant mais peu importe
mais rien à faire pourquoi il ya eu cet
accord parce que l'australie est aussi
aujourd'hui son rival pour ne pas dire
plus c'est bien sûr la chine est donc
cet accord a été conclu pour la bonne
raison que les etats-unis offraient à
l'australie des sous marins à propulsion
nucléaire qui sont pratiquement
invisibles sous l'eau et qui ont une
capacité d'action sur une hausse bien
supérieure à quoi sous marin oui à tout
débat dit à guy bord de la moto sur
justement ces sous-marins
bon temps dès
aujourd'hui oui donc oui mais enfin bon
et vous lire ajustements libre eu la
mode là dessus oui aubin sur les sur les
avantages respectifs des sous-marins dl
/ / / nucléaire enfin pour la région
compte tenu des besoins de l'australie
compte tenu du délai du calendrier tout
ça est très débattue en australie donc
bon la question n'est pas tranchée je
crois que je crois qu'en fait ça surtout
été une décision politique de se
rapprocher du royaume-uni et des
etats-unis parce que parce que
2 valent mieux qu'un mais alors
justement quelle est l'influencé de la
france maintenant dans cette zone pardon
de vous avoir interrompu en hameaux
pierre antoine launay
écoutez si vous voulez moi je crois
qu'il faut replacer tout ça dans un
contexte de conflits idéologiques à vrai
dire c'est une chine communiste
totalitaire faut bien le dire c'est bien
ça face à des pays démocratiques
la présidence de taiwan dit bien souvent
ce qui est en jeu c'est la démocratie
dans le monde et taiwan c'est un verrou
très important stratégique pour
l'ensemble de la région si d'aventuré
les états unis devaient lâcher taïwan
mais ce serait un signal extrêmement
fort pour tous les alliés de l'est des
etats-unis dans la région asie-pacifique
et c'est bien pour ça que la chine par
les états unis ne lâcherons pas jean
joseph boillot ajustements la ion
revient ce que dit puis on tenait sur
cette opposition démocratie autocratie
est ce que vous voyez le clivage à cet
endroit c'est ce que dit joe by
d'annoncer ce qui veut s'éviter la
grille lancée autour de lui ouais ouais
ouais maudit c'est un grand démocrate
il a l'âge des étoiles épaule touchée
gianni l'une des personnes bien sûr pas
de râler en géopolitique on n'est pas
sur les valeurs g il faut des valeurs
dans la vie mais en géopolitique c'est
plus compliqué et donc quand ils byden
il faut le quand même le savoir il avait
essayé de faire changer moody de
position sur la guerre en ukraine et spa
est d'ailleurs lors de ce sommet il ya
un peu des petites pressions mais très
vite moody a dit non voilà russie c'est
mon allié structurelles donc c'est
intangible non on parler d'ambition dès
la ligne et le poids des très
intéressant parce que c'est un ensemble
à mons à mon sens c'est un ensemble
d'ambiguïté les indiens il dans ce quad
ils défendent trois positions
stratégiques
la préparation à la guerre il y en a ils
se préparent à la guerre mais en même
temps une alliance sam draia c'est là le
point de leur doctrine très important et
puis enfin le double jeu et donc ce qui
perturbe un peu l'ensemble le japon et
l'inde s'entend très bien et il ya
vraiment une priorité stratégique
économique et politique entre le japon
et l'inde pourquoi face aux états unis
et au japon il faut quand même pas nous
dire que on adore le peuple américain on
adore la démocratie américaine c'est pas
si simple
ça c'est sûr qu'il avait passé dans les
deux danses et de prix vous avez un
revivalisme traditionalistes leur tour
un peu à des valeurs fondamentales et
c'est donc sans doute cdd mais au moins
c'est pas si simple quand même moi il ya
quand même un clivage quand même claire
entre des pays où il ya où il ya malgré
tout des élections qui sont pas
parfaites certes on était dedans
dégradation on est peut-être on a
peut-être un peu plus lisse qu'on n'aime
pas beaucoup maudit bon mais enfin ceci
étant on a quand même des pays qui
globalement fonctionne plus ou moins
comme des démocraties n'est ce pas enfin
se dire démocratiquement sans être
parfaite ce qui éclaire le piètre mon
dernier livre mais mais mais est
clairement face à ça on a un pays où il
ya aucune liberté ou hong konk était un
petit havre de liberté vient d'être
vient d'être complètement écrasée donc
cette logique de joe biden a tout de
même hâte ou même un sens avec les
conséquences du conflit ukrainien a skié
un rapprochement aujourd'hui entre la
chine et la russie pourtant tant qu'il
avait déjà là je prends ce que je pense
que la chine est pas particulièrement
enthousiasmés par cette aventure
ukrainienne sincèrement kiki qui
certainement la met un peu mal à l'aise
mais enfin c'est vrai qu'on la voit
fidèle aux côtés de la russie
incontestablement et je ne sais pas vous
parliez taiwan et d enseignement etc du
point de vue de deux des enseignements
qu'on peut tirer de la fiabilité de
l'occident à l'égard de l'ukraine enfin
je pense que là la chine a pu aussi se
rendre compte c'est très important je
trouve qu'on a mis beaucoup de temps à
réagir personnellement que les européens
ont été très désunis connan s'est montré
très lié à la fois par l'argument agité
nucléaire et puis et puis par les
questions énergétiques donc
et puis je pense qu'au final on s'est
décidé à tous agir parce qu'il fallait
donner un signalement seulement à la
russie et à la chine mais enfin on a mis
quand même on avait quand même du temps
à mettre de l'eau dans nos rangs donc ça
n'est pas un signal pour la chine en cas
d'attaqué de taïwan ce que vous dites on
ne dépasse pas clair s'est arrêté je
pense qu'on a on a réagi on a réagi
disant hey lalala bon pour pour la nôtre
notre crédibilité sentir tout juste ça
correspond donc j'aimerais quand même
qu'on revienne à ce communiqué final il
ya eu des déclarations de ben ali
c'est très important dans le communiqué
final on dit bien que on ne reconnaît
diplomatiques bon que la chine
continentale la corse est très important
délit n'aurais pas signé si non et
deuxièmement on s'en allait à l'île
autonome des moyens militaires pour se
défendre ah ben ça c'est la réitération
de la position non mais c'est ça qui est
très important on reste les promesses
qui n'engagent que les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui y croient qu est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
c'est très compliqué ce qui est en train
de se passer en asie pacifique et
qu'effectivement c'est ce que je vous
dis je reste persuadé on n'est pas dans
un affrontement de blocs pour l'instant
on est dans la construction d'un nouvel
équilibre et je trouve très positif ce
sommet de ce point de vue là parce
qu'ils montrent que face à la chine il
ya effectivement des gens qui sont
capables et et simplement l'un devient
maître d'être que la violence est d'être
non-alignés d'être de faire bloc sans
que ce soit et ne débloquent au sens de
2,2 de la guerre froide de faire bloc
contre ces velléités d'expansion je
préfère utiliser l'expression
expansionnisme de la chine c'est la
seule raison d'ailleurs qui justifie la
présence de l'inde il faut pas l'oublier
c'est bloqué l'expansionnisme chinois
non seulement dans l'himalaya mais
surtout ce qu'elle voit depuis quelques
années dans les mers et c'est pour ça
que l'essentiel de quad c'est dans les
mers et c'est pour ça que votre question
sur la france est très importante parce
que leur a répondu le vent tâche en
levant tapson droite c'est l'europe sur
le
quad le quad est quand même et quand
même une construction qui vient de plus
en plus complexe et c'est d'ailleurs un
terrain intéressant à observer on est
parti des exercices navals et puis il ya
eu les vaccins pendant la crise
sanitaire il ya le changement climatique
on voit des sommets qui
s'institutionnalise qui sont à
différents niveaux maintenant qu'ils
sont plus en plus réguliers qui sont
entre entre
entrecoupé de dialogue donc on a on a
quand même un changement et mais enfin
on n'est pas du tout dans une structure
type autant institut
sénégalais lundi étendre aurait donc ça
poserait problème n'est pas du tout dans
cette dans cette approche en effet sur
taïwan pour vous répondre on est dans un
maintien en fait du statu quo ce qui est
important du point de vue des
occidentaux s'il s'agit pas d'aller
provoquer inutilement la chine sait pas
du tout ce que l'on cherche à faire donc
donc de fait on répète qu'elle n'a pas
vu comme une provocation elle ce quoi
les régies ses membres oui effectivement
quand tout quand même on essaie de
maintenir un minima les les signaux qui
peuvent être interprétés comme étant
civile il faut donner des signaux qui
montrent qu'on est con et malgré tout
vigilants et ferme mais mais en même
temps ne pas ne pas pousser ne pas faire
monter les le sentiment de le n'exerce
us très difficile de détacher une cale
est qu'elle est quel hacker la face à
elle d'aider des pays hostiles dix ans
et la france le fait effectivement qui
est pas la france n'est pas l'europe en
termes de sécurité pardon le dilemme de
sécurité ça s'appelle mais pourquoi
la proche de rejoindre le quan ho non
alors là sur la france non j'étais sur
la sur la chine sur la sur la france
pour la montre pour le moment là la
france est pas invité donc à rejoindre
le coin même de quoi de plus elle même
était oui on peut dire qu'avec la corée
du sud avec la nouvelle zélande il ya eu
plusieurs états ont été invités à
rejoindre le quoi de plus donc ce format
à la france manquait les présentant dans
cette zone et feront tout de même et pas
le royaume uni non plus donc on est on
est sur un autre fin dans le dans le
regard américain disant encore il ya ce
quad qui rassemble et puissance de
l'inde au pacifique et puis il ya
séparément malgré tout encore le
royaume-uni et la france alors même le
royaume uni et dans une alliance
justement avec ce
n'est pas vraiment une alliance plus en
plus c'est pas une à lyon ok ce n'est
pas une alliance non plus et ça a vécu
c'est un accord technologique qui en un
volet qui concerne les sous marins mais
beaucoup d'autres auxquelles le japon
désespère espère s'associer intelligence
artificielle énergie quantique et c'est
donc on est grand que la france eh bien
peut-être la france avec la nouvelle
administration précisément australienne
en tout cas
oui il est pas il n'est pas exclu en
tout cas en tout cas si les les français
voulaient se rapprocher un peu
l'australie il paraît difficile d'éviter
l'australie dans la région ce serait le
moment de le faire et je pense qu'en
effet l'administration australienne
nouvelle n'a pas n'a pas n'est pas
particulièrement fiers disons de la
manière dont scott morrison a géré en
effet 7 7
cette la fin à la rupture brutale en
effet du contrat avec les français alors
que alors que les français sont un
partenaire utile a minima dans la dans
cette région mais en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il pense oui je pense que l'inde va
faire rentrer en v et et c'est ça qui va
se passer très très clairement pourquoi
pas ce que va faire entrer la france
bien sûr d'ores et déjà il ya des
exercices navals important et donc et la
relation stratégique entre la france et
l'inde est très très forte je ne vois
pas comment la france ne rentrera pas dé
facto mais qu'est ce qui bloque
attendait c'est les états unis il faut
faut dire les papilles un chat un chat
c'est à dire que la france est un peu
fouteuse de merde ce qui vient de se
passer en ukraine c'est pas très net
quand même et donc dans ce que vous
indiquez sur le fait qu'il ya eu une
mollesse de réaction etc etc je crois
que tant que les états unis peuvent se
retrouver un peu en asie pacifique un
peu tout seul il préfère jeanjean
passion je pense qu'ils sont ils sont
satisfaits franchement d'avoir d'autres
partenariats mais je crois qu'il ya
cette main se maintient disons d'un d'un
cercle de plus plus plus restreint avec
les puissances du pacifique qui pour le
moment distincts mais enfin ça veut pas
dire qu'ils aient pas des dialogues
séparément est en effet une coopération
de sécurité trilatéral entre australie
et 1d france qui existait auparavant qui
pourrait très bien être réactivée
lapointe s'est de fait rapprocher de
l'inde après la presle fallout avec les
australiens dont on voit pas bien
comment en effet l'australie et la
france pourrait rester en froid
sincèrement très traître merci ça sera
le mot de la fin merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous guy bourg de la motte
merci beaucoup jean joseph boillot merci
à vous bien antoine nodet d'avant était
avec tous par sky merci sonia sonia
dridi qui étaient avec nous en direct de
washington merci à vous tous deux heures
suivi vous restez avec nous 124
[Musique]